pessoal um dos repelentes mais eficazes
conhecido é aquele a base de icaridina
esse composto é altamente eficiente
contra o mosquito transmissor da dengue
sendo recomendado por sua longa duração
de ação Além disso é impossível não
mencionar os repelentes naturais como é
o caso da citronela e o óleo de hortelã
pimenta a citronela seja em forma de
óleo essencial ou mesmo cultivada ao
redor da sua casa é famosa por afugentar
os mosquitos com sua fragância no
mercado há uma vasta gama de produtos
contendo citronela de devido a sua
eficácia reconhecida por outro lado o
óleo de hortelã pimenta tem se destacado
em pesquisas por reduzir notavelmente as
picadas dos mosquitos da dengue mais
atenção ao uso de acordo com as
instruções do fabricante já que pode
causar irritação na pele em algumas
pessoas Vale ressaltar também que embora
efetivos esses repelentes naturais podem
necessitar de reaplicações mais
constantes em comparação a e caridina
devido ao tempo de ação mais limitado